deschamps en manque de main d'oeuvre le
coït 19 a mis l'accent sur une réalité
dans le monde agricole
la dépendance de notre pays à la main
d'oeuvre étrangère du fait des
fermetures des frontières
on a eu vraiment beaucoup de peine à les
faire venir dans les champs c'est une
tradition depuis l'après-guerre des
ouvriers espagnols viennent prêter main
forte
il reste en france le temps de la saison
essentiellement dans les vignes à cette
époque
et voilà cette main d'oeuvre compense le
manque d'ouvriers français dans les
champs la pénurie est telle qu'un accord
avec l'espagne a été ciblée en 1961 pour
favoriser la venue des travailleurs
saisonniers en particulier pour
l'agriculture
deux ans plus tard en 1963 un accord du
même type est passé avec les pays du
maghreb
le système est très organisé les
travailleurs sont déclarés pour six mois
comme l'expliquent en exploitant 1960
ils ont les salaires qui sonde établie
par une commission mixte avec les
syndicats ouvriers de charente et
charente maritime
et comme dans tous les départements
viticole derrière et ils nous disons
exactement les mêmes conditions de
travail de salaire et de sécurité
sociale que les travailleurs français
année après année le nombre d'ouvriers
saisonniers espagnols et maghrébins a
diminué au profit d'autres nationalités
dans les années 90 des travailleurs
d'europe de l'est ont pris le relais en
particulier n'est polonais dans ce
verger par exemple j'ai travaillé
des trois mois c'est la même qu'en
pendant six mois la suisse vous voudriez
être changés sont payés au smic plus des
heures supplémentaires du moins pour
ceux embauchés en toute régularité pour
les autres ce qu'on ne voit pas dans les
reportages de travail au noir et
journées interminables
ils sont à la merci des patrons comme le
dénonce un ouvrier cgt en 2007 et
profite des déjantés
comment je vais vous expliquer il faut
qu'ils ferment leur gueule pour qu'ils
puissent revenir la lande ap en près de
60 ans les ouvriers agricoles étrangers
sont devenus incontournables dans notre
pays
d'après les derniers chiffres de
l'office français de l'immigration il
date de 2016 en agriculture 80 pour cent
de la main d'oeuvre est étrangère
[Musique]